vor nicht mal 100 tagen tritt die neue
regierung ihr amt an die welt ist da
noch eine andere
russlands angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
wird folgen haben auch für berlin der 24
februar 2022 markiert eine zeitenwende
wenn uns gewählt eine andere ist dann
muss auch unsere politik eine andere
sein
für mich ist es eine bittere eskalation
einer politischen realität die viele
nicht wahrnehmen wollten
schonungslos legt putins krieg die
versäumnisse deutscher politik offen dem
zustand der bundeswehr die abhängigkeit
vom russischen gas
in dramatischen stunden bringt der
kanzler deutschland auf einen neuen kurs
olaf scholz war absolut ein getriebener
der ereignisse er hatte in der
entscheidenden phase wenig kontrolle der
krieg wird politik parteien gesellschaft
verändern dass in den ersten 100 tagen
ja weiterhin die krone pandemie
bewältigen müssen das war irgendwann
schon klar dass jetzt noch ein krieg
dazu kommt mit den seelischen
schockwellen und wirtschaftlichen
schockwellen für uns alle das war nicht
absehbar
ich verstehe alle menschen die sagen
wenn man die bilder sieht wo kleine
jungs fallend über die grenze gehen wir
müssen mehr machen aber
dieses mehr machen hat keinen preis so
und nun kommt die frage ist die
bevölkerung bereit einschränkungen ihres
wohlstands hinzunehmen
[Musik]
die neue zeit sie ist auch abzulesen an
zahlen an den tankstellen im land
zahlen die millionen menschen betreffen
[Musik]
wir sind bei 125 euro
kann ich darüber nachdenken weil ich
musste es einfach benutzen um damit zur
arbeit zu kommen ich war neu in berlin
war ein deutscher markt- oder sogar dass
jetzt zwei euro heißt fiat deutschland
ich bin darauf angewiesen ist muss es
mir leisten also ich komm nicht warum
also früher habe ich 40 euro vielleicht
die woche getankt jetzt danke ich die
wörter für 50 euro das ist wirkt sich
daher auf alles aus weil wenn die
transportunternehmen deutlich höhere
kosten haben durch die erhöhten
benzinpreise wird dadurch natürlich auch
jede ware teurer
auch wenn der krieg in der ukraine
einige hundert kilometer entfernt ist
erschüttert er die deutsche wirtschaft
robert habeck ist der zuständige
minister nicht mal 100 tage im amt
hastet er jetzt von einem krisentreffen
zum nächsten
denn energiekosten sind immer auch eine
soziale frage
menschen die wird schon an der
armutsschwelle leben die wirklich wenig
haben die sind natürlich jetzt doppelt
hart betroffen und man kann sie nicht in
die komplette armut rutschen lassen dass
man in solch einer situation alles
kompensieren kann das ist wahrscheinlich
nicht möglich
eigentlich wollte sich der grüne vize
kanzler als superminister um den kampf
gegen den klimawandel kümmern jetzt geht
es um die sicherheit der versorgung mit
gas öl und kohle
meine arbeit für die arbeit der
bundesregierung heißt das auch dafür zu
sorgen dass wir unabhängiger von öl oder
kohle aus dem können werden daran
arbeiten wir die ganze zeit und
permanent
deutschland ist die viertgrößte
wirtschaft der welt und braucht energie
sehr viel energie 70 prozent davon muss
im ausland eingekauft werden wenn es mit
dem nachschub probleme gibt betrifft es
alle viele arbeitsplätze stehen auf dem
spiel aber auch die einkommen werden sie
denn wenn die inflation steigt und dass
das geld was sie eine tasche haben nicht
zunimmt dann verlieren sie an kaufkraft
und das wird die realität für die große
mehrheit der deutschen in diesem jahr
sein
das finanzministerium in berlin auch
hier gibt es seit knapp 100 tagen einen
neuen vermögensverwalter keine
steuererhöhungen einhalten der
schuldenbremse und sparsames haushalten
mit diesen zielen ist christian lindner
angetreten ich bin in großer sorge es
gibt viel solidarität mit der ukraine
aber wir haben eben auch negative
auswirkungen auf uns die erholung nach
corona verzögert sich wir hatten ohnehin
aufgrund von lieferengpässen und
nachholenden effekten
preissteigerungen befürchtet das hat
sich jetzt noch mal dramatisch
verschärft
was bedeutet das alles für die menschen
weit weg von der hauptstadt kevin
kühnert ist generalsekretär der
kanzlerpartei spd vergangene woche reist
er nach kirche in die nähe von
saarbrücken im saarland wird ende märz
2022 ein neuer landtag gewählt und
kühnert macht wahlkampf von tür zu tür
von den hohen energiepreisen das sind
wir natürlich sehr betroffen haben
ganzen tags lichtern hier müssen heizen
mit gas
wo das endet weiß ja auch keiner die
preisspirale gibt ja immer höher
wir als kleine einzelhändler
die marke wird nicht so groß sein dass
man jetzt hier beliebig alles abfedern
kann was sie ja ja zusätzlich auf
natürlich schlägt auch alles auf das
merkt man auch die transportkosten der
lieferanten die schlagen das schon drauf
sie merkten auch eine gewisse
kaufzurückhaltung
bei den leuten
ja schon
jawohl wir haben irgendwas geht immer
bei müssen
ein paar schritte entfernt das
sozialkaufhaus leuchtender stern
wenn wir nur noch arbeite geht hervor
dass sprit zu finanzieren oder die
heizung
die lebensmittel sind jahr stark
gestiegen muss man ja in fast die müssen
ja auch nicht was trennt also man ganz
viele kunde die wurde wirklich sehr
traurig darüber sind was an ich kann mir
das einfach nicht mehr leisten die
einige wo das auto müsse stehen lassen
ja ist schon schön schlimm im moment
die ereignisse überschlagen sich die
russische militär offensive in der
ukraine hat also begonnen es ist von
beschuss von explosionen von
raketenbeschuss zu hören in den großen
städten
[Musik]
24 februar 2000 22 10 uhr morgens das
sicherheitskabinett kommt zusammen
dorthin hat in der ukraine über nacht
fakten geschaffen die neue regierung in
berlin hat es nun mit einem krieg zu tun
ich habe es morgens erfahren aus
der lage unterrichtung also am sehr
frühen morgen und es haben sich dann
alle befürchtungen die man haben muster
in tragischer weise bestätigt und wie
man heute weiß ist die realität noch
tragischer schlimmer grauenvoller als
das was man befürchten musste ja das war
ja ein sehr konkreter tag und der
emotionale moment und die welt wird eine
andere und jetzt müssen wir
entscheidungen treffen die nicht im
koalitionsvertrag stehen fielen zusammen
putins angriff auf die ukraine offenbar
dem jahrelangen selbstbetrug deutsche
russlandpolitik die hoffnung in putin
einen berechenbaren und ehrlichen
verhandlungspartner zu haben für mich
ist das eine bittere eskalation einer
politischen realität die viele nicht
wahrnehmen wollte man hat relativ lange
ja auch versucht
die regelbrüche putins mit denen er sich
strategische vorteile verschafft hat
kleinzureden wegzureden zu ignorieren
neun tage vor kriegsbeginn olaf scholz
preist nach moskau der öffentliche druck
auf ihn ist groß mehr präsenz in
russland ukraine konflikt wird von ihm
gefördert
treffen mit putin im kreml schon der
verhandlungstisch ein bild für die
geschichtsbücher der russische präsident
weiß da schon dass er ernst machen wird
auf die frage des deutschen kanzlers ob
er mit einem einmarsch russischer
truppen in die ukraine rechnen müsse
soll putin geschwiegen haben ich glaube
dass das bemühen mit putin ins gespräch
zu kommen die seien sehr lange vorlauf
wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen er wurde
er medial getrieben ist jetzt endlich
mal in die gänge kommen dann ist er zu
putin gereist hat er dreieinhalb stunden
gesessen und ich muss da klar geworden
sein dass die beiden völlig einander
vorbei reden das ist zurück kommen dann
immer noch in der hoffnung es passiert
nichts und dann
dieses sehen dass putin gelogen hat in
einer anderen welt lebt ich glaube dass
das so ein frust ausgelöst hat bei ihm
dass das aus dem tiefen inneren kam das
jetzt einfach schluss ist
am abend der russischen invasion hält
der kanzler eine rede an die nation
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
heute ist ein furchtbarer tag für die
ukraine wir hatten hoffnung aber wir
waren nicht naiv ab dezember wurde
regierungsinternen gearbeitet an
unterschiedlichen szenarien und was zu
tun ist welche engpässe bestehen wie man
sich rüsten kann worst case szenario
hatten wir durchgespielt zweieinhalb
monate lang und deswegen sind wir auch
vorbereitet gewesen nicht auf alles aber
wir haben angefangen gas zu kaufen wir
hatten mit den versorgern gesprochen die
pläne für die lg terminals waren klar
wir hatten stille eingerichtet
rückblick schon im november 2000 21
beginnt russland massiv truppen an der
grenze zur ukraine zusammen zu ziehen
mehr als 100000 soldaten
im januar stimmen mehrere nato-staaten
zu waffen an die ukraine zu liefern
deutschland das dach von lieferungen
immer abgelehnt hat bleibt bei dem
kategorischen nein beschränkt sich auf
symbol gesten
der hand es sofort geprüft und wir
werden 5000 helme an die ukraine liefern
auch als ganz deutliches signal wir
stehen an eurer seite in der ukraine
bereiten sie sich unterdessen vor den
augen der welt auf den krieg vor
wladimir klitschko boxweltmeister im
schwergewicht
jetzt meldet er sich in kiew freiwillig
als reservist
sein bruder peter liese 2014
bürgermeister von kiew gibt interview um
interview
deutschland ist die zweite heimat der
brüder hier haben sie lange geliebt an
deutschland richtet sich vitali
klitschko direkt wir wollen
wir brauchen waffen
danke für helme aber das ist nie genug
die ukrainische regierung ist irritiert
über die deutsche haltung als die
aussenministerin am 17 februar nach kiew
reist hat präsident selensky keine zeit
für sie baerbock fährt weiter in die ost
ukraine hier im donbass kämpfen seit
2014 ukrainische soldaten gegen
russische separatisten dass die
aussenministerin kurz nach amtsantritt
hierher reist an die sogenannte kontakt
linie ist ein signal der burg will damit
die aufmerksamkeit auf die kriegsfront
in europa lenken
das dorf das direkt an der kontakt linie
liegt ist seit acht jahren verlassen und
verdient
[Musik]
überall einschusslöcher
1400 menschen haben hier mal gelebt
die deutsche außenministerium wird
begleitet von ihrer ukrainischen
amtskollegin und journalisten
nur 16 tage später wird putins kriegt
realität für die ganze ukraine und die
bundesregierung gerät jetzt
international unter druck sich mehr zu
engagieren
zwei tage lang weicht scholz nicht ab
von den jahrzehntelang gefestigten
deutschen positionen keine waffen keine
aufrüstung
dann reißt er das ruder rum
olaf scholz war absolut ein getriebener
der ereignisse ich denke schon dass
diese fundamentale entscheidung aus der
situation heraus kam dass hier ein
politisch eher unerfahrener kanzler auf
einem festen kurs war der ihn letztlich
mit dem rücken zur wand oder mit dem
gesicht zur wand man kann es sehen wie
man will gestellt hat und dann musste er
diese kehrtwende einleiten ja ich würde
mal sagen dass der kanzler gewissermaßen
auf den letzten drücker die kurve
gekriegt hat und dass er nachdem er in
vielen fragen vorher als ein zauderer
und
zeit gewinner da gestanden hat
an diesem tag statur gewonnen hat
und sich auch in vieler hinsicht aus dem
langen und breiten schatten seiner
vorgängerin emanzipiert hat
deutschland liefert nun
verteidigungswaffen in die ukraine mit
finanzminister lindner entwickelt scholz
die idee vom milliardenschweren
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
der bundeskanzler und ich haben
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
diskutiert steuererhöhungen dauerhaftes
ausreichend der schuldenbremse des
grundgesetzes beides verträgt nicht zur
wirtschaftlichen stärke unseres landes
bei und deshalb habe ich den vorschlag
entwickelt und konkretisiert über ein
zweckgebundenes einmaliges
sondervermögen die
jahrzehntelange vernachlässigung der
bundeswehr in einigen schritten jetzt zu
beenden
es ist die kehrtwende des fdp
finanzministers der abschied vom sparen
dabei ist die staatsverschuldung schon
jetzt so hoch wie nie zuvor
2011 stoppte die schuldenbremse den
rasanten anstieg nach der
wiedervereinigung
doch die korona krise die investitionen
für den klimaschutz und das
sondervermögen bundeswehr werden wohl
die schulden in die höhe treiben
[Musik]
dieses geflügelte wort das ist christian
jetzt lieber geschichte schreiben möchte
als eine schwarze null oder in schwarzen
haushalt das ist schon finde ich in ihm
sehr zu merken also der merkt man die
halterung so bord erwartet tags so ich
gebe das geld wenn es gebraucht wird das
hätte man von ihm natürlich zu beginn
der legislatur auch nicht erwartet
dieser krieg wird bedeuten dass der
deutsche staat sich in den kommenden
zwei drei vier jahren massiv neu
verschulden muss einmal um die den krieg
zu bekämpfen die auswirkungen die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen höhere
energiepreise eine wirtschaftliche
rezession
aber eben auch um notwendige
zukunftsinvestitionen zu tätigen auch
die wirtschaftlichen folgen dieses
krieges zeigen sich immer deutlicher vor
allem bei den energiepreisen der
gaspreis explodierte heute regelrecht
+60 prozent kaum besser die lage beim öl
seit dem russischen angriff geht es
massiv nach oben aus angst vor dem
ausfall russischer quellen
die rasant steigenden heizkosten treffen
alle die auf fossile brennstoffe wie gas
oder öl angewiesen sind wer wenig
verdient muss heute schon bis zu zehn
prozent seines einkommens für eine warme
wohnung ausgeben
dass ich weniger heizen werde
meldet sonst zu teuer wird wenn man
volle pulle man könnte jetzt schon sagen
so wie es vielleicht früher war sie
heißen jetzt nur noch diesen einen raum
und halten uns da drin die ganze zeit
auf aber wir sind halt gewöhnen dass die
ganze wohnung halt waren es viele sind
schon so weit dass es schon versucht
haben an allen möglichen ecken und enden
zu sparen was heizen betrifft ich
erinnere mich an einen satz meiner
mutter die noch aus kriegstagen
berichtete die dann später nach dem
krieg sagte lieber habe ich ein
stückchen weniger brot aber ich habe es
war mehr
als die hälfte des gases das wir
verbrauchen kommt aus russland zwar wird
trotz des krieges weiter geliefert doch
die speicher sind gerade mal zu einem
viertel gefüllt
ein szenario mit dem die politik sich
dringend auseinandersetzen muss was ist
wenn von heute auf morgen russland den
gas export nach deutschland einstellen
dann fehlt uns viel energie das können
wir nicht so schnell ersetzen in
brunsbüttel an der elbmündung soll jetzt
eine alternative zum russischen gas
entstehen ein hafen an dem flüssiggas
sogenanntes lng entladen werden kann
bisher hat deutschland keine solche
anlage deshalb ist minister habeck heute
gekommen eigentlich dauert ein solches
vorhaben jahre und nun wünscht sich der
grüne den turbo
dem kommunalen planungsbehörden und mit
den verantwortlichen der landesregierung
meinen ehemaligen kollegen ob wir nicht
mal ein kleines chaos und erschaffen
wollen nämlich nicht eine halbe ewigkeit
brauchen sondern das ganze ding
durchziehen ich hoffe wenn wir uns
jemals mal wieder aus dieser deutschen
bräsigkeit und schlafmützigkeit und
umständlichkeit befreien wollen dann
doch wohl jetzt das flüssiggas
denn je kommt vor allem als tracking gas
aus den usa australien und katar für den
transport muss es auf minus 162 grad
gekühlt werden russisches pipelinegas
ist dagegen umweltfreundlicher für den
mann der als klimaminister angetreten
ist eigentlich eine katastrophe
die terminals hat man bisher nicht
gebaut weil man sich einseitig auf dem
ostring 2 und damit auf russisches gas
verlassen hat das ist auch günstiger das
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen pipeline
gebundenes gas günstiger als das mit
tankschiffen zu holen aber wir müssen
uns ja jetzt endlich weiter aufstellen
moskau stadt brunsbüttel das war über
jahrzehnte die devise der regierung
merkel jetzt ist die pipeline nord
stream 2 gestoppt um die abhängigkeit
von russland in zeiten des krieges nicht
noch weiter zu erhöhen bitteres ende
einer fehlgeleiteten energiepolitik
wir sehen nicht zum ersten mal das gas
als politische waffe eingesetzt wird
russland hat mehrfach schon den gashahn
abgedreht davon wollen wir nicht
unmittelbar betroffen aber dass die
pipeline auch diesen zweck dient die
erste aber auch die zweite die ukraine
zu umgehen hier auch geopolitische ziele
mit umzusetzen das war von vornherein
klar auch die strategie wandel durch
handel ist gescheitert enge
wirtschaftliche verflechtungen haben
putin nicht von seinem angriffskrieg
abgehalten und ihn sogar reich gemacht
die politik muss sich letztlich auf alle
eventualitäten nach alle szenarien
vorbereiten also auch darauf dass der
krieg lange andauert mehrere jahre
möglicherweise
muss sich darauf vorbereiten dass wir
von gasimporten aus russland
abgeschnitten werden dass wir innerhalb
eines jahres eine komplette energiewende
brauchen es gibt jetzt schon
einschränkungen es gibt jetzt schon
probleme wir sehen nicht nur bei den
energieleistungen
versorgungsprobleme wir sehen
mittlerweile auch im bereich der
nahrungsmittel
versorgungsprobleme nur zur erinnerung
die ukraine ist ja nicht nur das
zweitgrößte europäische land nach fläche
sondern die ukraine ist einer der
hauptproduzenten von saatgut von
getreide dieses land ist so sagt man ist
die kornkammer europas am weltfrauentag
macht spd-generalsekretär kevin kühnert
straßenwahlkampf in saarbrücken
die menschen in deutschland werden wohl
sparsamer leben müssen auch dass eine
neue realität
in den nächsten tagen bin ich mir sicher
wird die diskussion darauf hinauslaufen
sind wir bereit dass das heizen und das
tanken jetzt teurer wird dafür dass wir
haben gut in die daumenschrauben ein
bisschen andrehen ich glaube das ist
sehr verkürzt dass wir gegeneinander
zocken dabei die kunden wieder schaut
sie rechtlich schwierig war bereit den
pressesaal
hinzu ja aber ich bin bereit den preis
zu zahlen weil wenn ich mir das so was
da
los ist und das ist mein beitrag
was dieser tag gezeigt hatte in der
deutschen politik und zwar über weite
teile des bundestages hinweg spd und
grüne und fdp und cdu und csu dieses
land wird sich ändern und zwar deutlich
sonntag 27
februar 2022 ein tag für die
geschichtsbücher
der kanzler kommt zur
regierungserklärung ins parlament nur
wenige ahnen was er gleich verkünden
wird finanzminister lindner ist
eingeweiht
olaf scholz sucht die nähe zu den
abgeordneten er weiß was sie nicht
wissen dass er knapp 20 minuten später
deutschlands politischen kurs
grundlegend verändern wird über nacht
im alleingang
[Musik]
zu dem zeitpunkt als scholz ans
rednerpult trat war eine handvoll leute
informiert darüber was er wirklich
vorhatte bis in die details um 11.25
kommt der kanzler vom entscheidenden
punkt in seiner rede der aufrüstung des
deutschen militärs jahrzehntelang in
deutschland undenkbar
wir werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
und ich bin bundesfinanzminister lindner
sehr dankbar für seine unterstützung
dabei
der bundeskanzler kam auf mich zu und
hat unterstrichen dass nach seiner
auffassung jetzt die äußere sicherheit
und bündnisfähigkeit deutschlands
gestärkt werden müsse davon musste er
mich nicht überzeugen das ist schon
lange auch meine meinung gewesen und ich
habe dann vorschläge unterbreitet der
bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten die mittel
werden der für notwendige investitionen
größten gericht vorhaben noch
präsident putin sollte unsere
entschlossenheit nicht unterschätzen
gemeinsam mit unseren alliierten jeden
quadratmeter des bündnisgebietes zu
verteidigen was er einen satz gesagt hat
wir werden jeden quadratmeter nato bodes
verteidigen einen solchen satz habe ich
von eingeladen hatte nie gehört und das
ist eine völlig neue kategorie so zum
ersten mal seit 30 jahren
deutet ein bundeskanzler an der
bundeskanzlerin an wir denken die
bundeswehr wieder über den krieg nämlich
über eine kriegs fähigkeit diese klare
botschaft hier hat mich sehr erstaunt
ich finde sie richtig
und manchmal ist es ja so dass
diejenigen die sich mit einer position
schwer getan haben dann in historische
situation sie ändern dass das an eine
besondere wucht hat und auch eine
besondere nachhaltigkeit
auf der ehrentribüne sitzt an diesem tag
altbundespräsident joachim gauck einer
der von deutschland immer mehr
verantwortung und militärische stärke
verlangt hat nun sitze ich an einem
sonntag im deutschen bundestag und höre
wie mein bundeskanzler dinge verspricht
und als politik ins werk setzt wo ich
dachte ich träume endlich wurde wieder
begriffen dass selbst wenn man
feindbilder scheut und ein menschen des
friedens ist man wie so naiv sein darf
sein schafft nicht als feindschaft zu
erkennen
100 milliarden euro sondervermögen um
deutschland wehrhaft zu machen viele
parlamentarier merken erst nach und nach
was sie da gerade gehört haben die
opposition ganz links und ganz rechts
ist entsetzt wirkt gelähmt
abgeordnete der union und der fdp stehen
spontan auf klatschen
die grünen bleiben sitzen überrumpelt
wenn dann so eine große summe auf den
tisch gehauen wird da sind natürlich
erst mal viele perplex und legen sich
hey ich kämpfe gerade ja in meinem
einzelplan dafür dass wir da noch eine
halbe million irgendwie ausgeben und der
kanzler komplett wie sie das selber auch
gesagt haben mit so einer bazooka um die
ecke und dann kann man auch schon mal
ein bisschen sage ich mal überrascht
sein der kanzler hat offenbar die
eingeweiht die er für seinen plan
braucht oppositionsführer märz gehört
dazu scholz weiß ein sondervermögen im
grundgesetz benötigt die
zweidrittelmehrheit und die union steht
für mehr geld für die bundeswehr bereit
der bundeskanzler hat auch mich
persönlich an dem tag vor seiner
regierungserklärung darüber informiert
dass er einen vorschlag machen wird auch
die bundeswehr besser auszustatten naja
die reine zahl ist auf den ersten blick
natürlich überraschend auf der anderen
seite wenn man genau hinguckt was die
bundeswehr wirklich braucht dann sind
100 milliarden nicht zu viel
bis heute ist unklar ob der grüne vize
kanzler und die grüne außenministerin
über die genaue summe informiert waren
es gibt zwei szenarien was passiert ist
entweder das halte ich für das
wahrscheinliche robert habeck und
annalena baerbock ahnten beide die 100
milliarden oder ahnten dass es um eine
summe in diesem bereich gehen würde und
haben das aber sozusagen nach außen hin
nicht so deutlich gemacht oder haben
sich in nichtwissen gehüllt wenn man so
will oder sie wussten es vielleicht
wirklich nicht weit stolz ihn wirklich
auch gesagt oder signalisiert die
details wollte gar nicht wissen zu eurem
eigenen schutz dann hätten sie diese
zahl wirklich gewusst und hätten ihren
parteivorstand nichts gesagt ihren
leuten nichts gesagt wäre das natürlich
schon auch ein affront weil es hier um
fundamentale positionen der grünen geht
auch für den linken flügel der spd
werden die bundeswehr milliarden eine
zumutung sein der generalsekretär der
nicht eingeweiht war aber die
parteilinie vertreten muss wird in den
tagen danach hadern ich werde zu
denjenigen die es in der rede des
kanzlers in der bundestagssitzung
erfahren haben so wie fast alle im raum
dass ich jetzt 100 milliarden zusätzlich
für die bundeswehr ausgeben will ist ein
satz den hätten sie vor wenigen wochen
aus meinem mund nicht gehört auch in
zeiten der zeitenwende ist die
bundeswehr nachweispflicht ich dass das
geld nicht in dunklen kanälen versickert
insofern wird es jetzt nicht damit getan
sein einfach ein sondervermögen
einzurichten und zu sagen weiter wie
bisher nur mit noch mehr geld für die
grünen und für die spd geht das ganze
mit einem erheblichen risiko einher hier
sind lange gehegte gewissheiten der
grünen und der spd auf dem spiel und es
ist noch keineswegs gesagt wie das auf
die lange frist ausgehen wird am tag als
der kanzler das land militärisch auf
einen neuen kurs bringt demonstrieren in
berlin hunderttausende für den frieden
es ist der tag an dem klar wird dass
deutschland sein verhältnis zu krieg und
frieden wohl neubert ordnen müssen
hier geht es darum dass ein ganzes land
auf einen neuen kurs gebracht wurde auch
eine gesellschaft man muss sich
vorstellen da demonstrieren draußen
hunderttausende menschen in berlin gegen
den krieg und drinnen im reichstag
erklärt ihnen ihr bundeskanzler in
seiner regierungserklärung wir werden
uns für den krieg ganz neu puristen
ausrüsten wir werden einen nie gekannten
geldsegen ausschütten über der
bundeswehr über jahre hinweg fragen wir
mal ganz konkret das ist will ja keiner
hoffen und steht aktuell natürlich auch
nicht zur debatte das tatsächlich die
bundeswehr dieses land deutschland
verteidigen muss wäre sie dazu in der
lage aktuell nein
eine klare antwort nein
plötzlich ist sie wieder da die angst
vor einem krieg und die frage sind wir
sicher
definitiv sollten wir mehr geld für die
für die bundeswehr ausgeben da jetzt in
den letzten jahren sehr oft gespart
wurde unbedingt müssten wir das tun weil
ich komme aus einer soldaten familie und
ich habe gesehen wie die männer immer
schlechter ausgerüstet waren wenn wir
200 milliarden in
unserem militär stecken und nicht 100
milliarden klimaschutz beispielsweise
zeit schon ein bisschen unter verteilt
finde ich weil sie mal schweiz
mindestens genau so wichtig wie
sicherheit die bundeswehr muss
eigentlich vor anker zeit in der
gesellschaft war wehrdienst dann wird
die bevölkerung durch ständig mit dieses
problem konfrontiert ist ich glaube dass
diese hochrüstung
zu ungunsten der kinderpolitik falsche
weg ist
tatsache ist 30 jahre nach ende des
kalten krieges ist die bundeswehr nur
noch bedingt abwehrbereit
es betrifft alle truppenteile die
deutsche armee hat zu wenige panzer die
fahren zu wenige schiffe die in see
stechen können und so wenige flugzeuge
die fliegen
wir haben nach 1990 fall der mauer ost
west konflikt beendet die bundeswehr
radikal runter gespart und das bedeutet
ja nicht nur dass wir keine modernen
waffen mehr gekauft haben wir haben
infrastruktur verfallen lassen keine
ersatzteile mehr gekauft keine munition
weitgehend unbeachtet hat die deutsche
armee die fähigkeit verloren das land zu
verteidigen
auch die kanzlerin kam selten vorbei
frust selbst bei merkels militärberatern
wir sind ja im moment eine der
schlechtesten armeen
europas wir haben weniger schiffe im
einsatz als die kleinen niederlande
unser nachbarland
wir hatten stellenweise weniger
kampfpanzer als die schweiz wir sind
leicht drüber wir haben vielleicht 180
plusminus wirklich einsatzfähig von
diesem großgeräte und das brauchen wir
natürlich massiv gerade jetzt in
kontinentaleuropa ob marta puma dax
bieber oder lego an viele großgeräte der
bundeswehr tragen tiernamen und tun sich
noch schwer mit den bedingungen in der
freien wildbahn ganz oben in der
nahrungskette der kampfpanzer leopard 2
70 kilometer in der stunde schnell wenn
er den fährt
wir haben jetzt bei kampfpanzern eine
einsatzbereitschaft je nach bataillon
von rund 25 prozent
und wenn ich das vergleiche mit meiner
anfangszeit auch in dem
panzergrenadierbataillon da hatten wir
eigentlich immer eine verfügbarkeit von
80 bis 90 prozent ein besonders
deutliches beispiel die deutsche u boot
flotte zeitweise war keines der sechs
übrig gebliebenen hightech geräte
einsatzbereit es fehlten die notwendigen
ersatzteile
es gibt glaube ich keinen beispiel in
der modernen geschichte wo ein verfall
der eigenen kampfkraft so schweigend von
der führung von streitkräften zur
kenntnis genommen dabei hat die
bundeswehr der nato fest der zusagen
gemacht wenn ein bündnisfall eskaliert
sollen deutsche tornados amerikanische
atombomben zu ihren zielen tragen die
sogenannte nukleare teilhabe die
oldtimer haben teilweise vier jahrzehnte
auf dem buckel die instandhaltung
verschlingt milliarden jetzt sollen so
schnell wie möglich amerikanische 35
gekauft werden ohne abschreckung ohne
die wirklich aktive aufrechterhaltung
des friedens in dem ich deutlich machen
dass ich bereit bin den krieg zu führen
wird man den frieden auf dauer nicht
aufrechterhalten die abschreckung ist
nicht deshalb aus der welt weil man sie
in deutschland gerne aus der welt gehabt
hätte
aber für sie zum internationalen
frauentag ein blümchen in saarbrücken
erfährt kevin kühnert wie die kehrtwende
in sachen bundeswehr bei bürgerinnen und
bürgern ankommt
milliarden für das militär das treibt
viele menschen hier um
das geld wäre woanders wesentlich besser
aufgehoben ich glaube dass man mit
waffen so einen typ wie den putin
abschrecken kann dauerhaft ich bin das
ist doch egal meine ganze jugend war
geprägt von dieser angst die jetzt
wieder da ist was ich ganz schrecklich
finde ich kriege gänsehaut wenn ich
darüber reden und jetzt sind meine
kinder um die 20 die haben jetzt diese
angst die ich damals eigentlich immer
hatte jetzt kommt das alles wieder
zurück ich habe das gefühl keiner lernt
dazu das ist das was mich bewegt
es ist die angst vor einer neuen auf
rüstungsspirale die viele noch aus den
80er jahren kennen
hunderttausende gehen damals auf die
straße sie demonstrieren gegen die
aufstellung neuer atomarer raketen und
marschflugkörper in westeuropa ein juso
mitglied namens olaf scholz hält eine
flammende rede gegen die aufrüstung
gesehen haben gesehen haben auf ihren
computern dass sie angegriffen werden
und sie haben fast der halbe stunde
gebraucht um herauszufinden dass das
nicht stimmt
kanzler der spd ist damals helmut
schmidt er setzt sich für abschreckung
durch aufrüstung ein und wird für viele
friedensbewegte auch in der eigenen
partei zum feindbild durch ein
misstrauensvotum wird helmut schmidt
1982 gestürzt seine partei steht damals
nicht hinter ihm
40 jahre später ist aus dem früheren
juso mitglied oder scholz der spd
kanzler geworden
die spd ist immer bereit gewesen ihrer
führung die gefolgschaft aufzukündigen
wenn sie den eindruck hat dass diese
führung gegen ihre eigenen werte
verstößt sie hat helmut schmidt zwar
respektiert der asiatin gestürzt und
insofern steht die spd in einer massiven
spannung zwischen dem pazifismus ihres
linken flügels und der realpolitik ihres
rechten flügels das aber markiert für
die spd immer schon das potenzial für
eine zerreißprobe und dieses potenzial
ist auch jetzt vorhanden in der
auseinandersetzung zwischen olaf scholz
als dem realpolitiker auf der einen
seite und den kevin kühnert dem linken
flügel auf der anderen seite und den
neue politik muss nun auch eine
verteidigungsministerin der spd umsetzen
christine lambrecht
für die juristin ist die bundeswehr
neuland flug im luftwaffen-airbus nach
rumänien die verteidigungsministerin
will sich vor ort informieren begrüßung
durch ihren rumänischen amtskollegen auf
einem militärflughafen am schwarzen meer
die nato hat hier kampfflugzeuge
stationiert um die ostflanke des
bündnisgebietes abzusichern darunter
auch sechs deutsche eurofighter zusammen
mit italienischen kollegen wird der
luftraum kontrolliert der krieg in der
ukraine ist hier keine halbe flugstunde
entfernt
[Musik]
ja wir können gerne daran die maschine
ein bisschen ran
[Musik]
ist das ein problem
sagt sie nicht schon
sind es auch alle schafe was
die ministerin hat eine botschaft
mitgebracht
wir sind vorbereitet wir sind gut
aufgestellt und wir sind entschlossen
entschlossen unser bündnis zu
verteidigen hier wird keinen millimeter
gewissen das ist ein zeichen dass
gesendet werden muss
nach wenigen stunden macht sich die
verteidigungsministerin auf den heimweg
die eurofighter werden bis auf weiteres
bleiben
auch die grünen müssen sich auf die
neuen zeiten einstellen sara nanni ist
sicherheitspolitische sprecherin der
partei die aus der friedensbewegung
hervorgegangen ist joschka fischer hat
damals in der bundesregierung sehr
weitreichende entscheidung getroffen die
dazu nach umweltsong auch innerhalb der
mitgliedschaft geführt habe
1999 wird der damalige außenminister
dass sich die bundeswehr am kosovo
einsatz beteiligt joschka fischer wird
attackiert eine zerreißprobe für die
partei die grünen stimmen dem
kampfeinsatz schließlich zu um den
völkermord in der ehemaligen
jugoslawischen teilrepublik zu stoppen
es ist der erste auslandseinsatz der
bundeswehr bei dem auch geschossen wird
29 soldaten verlieren während der
kommission ihr leben für die grünen ein
wendepunkt und die ankunft in der
realpolitik
ich fand es richtig dass wir aus
humanitären gründen damals unsere
bundeswehr mit eingesetzt haben übrigens
auch unter rot grün das war ja auch eine
epochen entscheidung
auch die entscheidungen heute fühlen
sich für viele menschen pokal an
freiheit und frieden gibt es nicht zum
nulltarif
auch wenn wir das jetzt über jahrzehnte
so gewöhnt sind das glaube ich auf jeden
fall dass wir
wahrscheinlich verzichten müssen und
auch ein bisschen von unserem wohlstand
wahrscheinlich dafür aufgeben es wird ja
insgesamt jetzt sicher auch in die
lebensmittelbranche in alle polnischen
greifen nah ernten lieferungen öl ja das
ist das bläuliche einer ganzen situation
dass der kalte krieg jetzt wieder
neu eingeplant werden muss dann
wahrscheinlich über einen längeren
zeitraum wurde ich mal rechnen wir haben
jetzt ein enkel der sind jahre alt und
da denke ich oh je in was für ihre welt
ist der jetzt ein geborener
millionen menschen sind schon jetzt aus
der ukraine geflohen bis zu zehn
millionen könnten es werden sagen
experten die größte fluchtbewegung nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg der krieg hat die
friedensordnung in europa zerstört
wir gehen in eine welt rein die
vermutlich gekennzeichnet ist durch die
konkurrenz größer akteure um
einflussgebiete das ist eine welt die er
dem neunzehnten und im frühen
zwanzigsten jahrhundert entspricht als
den vorstellungen die wir uns zuletzt
gemacht haben glaube dass wir am 24
februar
2022 ja in einen wirklich neuen
zeitalter sicherheitspolitisch
angekommen sind denn es wird eine
dauerhafte konfrontation des westens mit
russland und china geben
was der krieg auch hervorbringt
solidarität
europa und die zivilgesellschaft stemmen
sich mit macht gegen putin die generelle
entwicklung angeht hat putin
dramatische fehler gemacht er die
wirkung von sanktionen unterschätzt er
hat die attraktivität der freiheit
unterschätzt europa steht zusammen ich
würde auch sagen dass wir eine
geschlossenheit und bewährte
geschlossenheit inzwischen wieder
hergestellt haben in europa und würde
den atlantik hinaus die werden der
vergangenheit nicht zu hatten putins
krieg wird deutschland viel abverlangen
müssen weniger heizen wir müssen weniger
auto fahren
weniger allgemein konsumieren das ist
die realität und darauf muss die politik
die bürgerinnen und bürgern auch die
wirtschaft vorbereiten und möglichst
viel stabilität gewährleisten wo werden
wir am ende stehen welchen wandel wird
unser land erleben wir werden zumindest
mal temporär mit einschränkungen leben
müssen und wir werden vielleicht den
wert dieses wohlstandes den wert dieser
freiheit und den wert von frieden wieder
neu einzuschätzen lernen ich habe kinder
ich habe enkelkinder ich hoffe dass wir
junge menschen überzeugen können dass
nur wer stark ist nicht angegriffen wird
deutschland hat sich gerade erst auf den
weg gemacht
meine größte sorge ist dass wir uns
zurück sehen in die zeit dessen wir sind
ja nicht betroffen und lasst uns in ruhe
und dass wir wieder zurückfallen in eine
form des begrenzten engagement
jetzt sind solidarität und verständnis
groß doch was wird wenn die neue
realität alltag ist
[Musik]